I'd like to welcome you to the third game.
Today's game is tug-of-war.
There are three targets between the two platforms.
In order to win, you must shoot the target marked by a lit green light.
For each successful shot, your team will be pushed further from the ledge.
Your opponents will be shoved closer in an attempt to drop your opponents down below.
The fifth game is glass stepping stones.
Stepping stones before you are made from one of two types of glass.
One will be tempered glass; the other will be normal.
The tempered glass stepping stones are strong enough to hold the weight of two players.
However, the normal glass will break, even if just one steps on it.
In this game, you will guess which one of the two next tiles is made of the stronger tempered glass.
You only step on those to cross the ten pairs of tile.
You may then cross over the other side safely and pass this game.
With that, let the game begin.